what do you think about infidelity
um you know what's the cause of
infidelity why do men and women cheat
it's different for everybody but I mean
even earlier I was saying with
adventurousness like if monogamy is
something you're doing
uh
I I I've seen in my own practice I've
seen the entire range of couples who are
open about having sexual relationships
with other people and fine with it
couples who want to be fine with it but
find out they're not
um uh couples who aren't just couples
couples with multiple people you know
multiple romantic relationships
um I've had couples where Affairs are
are tolerated and not talked about
um they're not enjoyed but they are not
the type of betrayal that will destroy
the relationship sort of a understanding
and keep it out of my face and then also
we won't talk about it so in the fair
that happened without getting permission
first and as long as you don't talk
about it it's not going to do a damage
to the relationship right but we can't
even talk about it like that right so
nobody's going to admit that the fair is
happening
um there can't be any evidence of it
it's sort of a just look the other way
type of a situation but uh the partner
who is not having the affair right they
typically know
um they certainly know that their
partner is capable of that
um they just kind of know but they don't
want it in their face it would become a
problem if it was in their face
um
as long as certain needs are met and
everything else is okay at home it's
just one of those things where don't ask
don't tell but that that's an
interesting point because I've I had a
bunch of arguments with people I tend to
hang out with especially in the tech
sector uh people who really value like
honesty and radical honesty and I keep
arguing with people about this because
to me it's not that simple okay that
that's an example right there uh that
Honesty can be really destructive like
honesty is also a really complicated
thing to get to the bottom of because
what is really honest yes and you know
like how do I look in this dress like
there's a million ways yeah a lot it can
be accessible in my mind if I'm in a bad
place or my partner and I am like if
Taya and I haven't been connected lately
my honesty of what I actually think
about him would be horrifically damaging
and completely unfounded also and but
and it can change on a dime and so
that's also not actual honesty to the
big picture of how you feel about him I
have interacted with a few folks who
talk about their previous sexual
partners for example on the numbers of
sexual partners they've had and they
feel like that's
that that kind of honesty is actually
empowering enriching to the relationship
because all the experienced sexual
experiences you've had in the past make
you a better sexual partner better
partner in in the present and to me from
the culture I've come from that's like
an anti-romantic yep like I you kind of
throw the past kind of away right you
don't really talk about it it's kind of
there in this amorphous shape but it's
almost as if you've met together for the
first time and this is a beautiful new
thing like your creatures that have
woken up from a long Slumber right
you're starting Anew it's starting in
new right so and then you want some
mystery there right I think the mystery
and like you have to figure that out
about each other so I'm not exactly sure
that honesty is always for everyone and
then also is honesty harmful or helpful
at certain points too yeah I.E so you're
talking about sort of like disclosing
prior sexual history I thought you were
going to go to so if you've had an
affair do you hold did you keep that
under your head oh yeah that's a really
tough question or are you obligated to
disclose it it's a really it is a very
tough question very tough well what do
you think is the I have my own personal
beliefs I also then like I have my
therapeutic beliefs I think frankly
and this is just me as a human being not
Shannon the psychologist
um I believe that if you have [__] up
and and I again I'm coming from a
framework right now of monogamy
um if you are committed to somebody you
love and you have [__] up you don't
get to shed your guilt onto them
you need to carry that burden it's not
necessarily I think it's simplistic and
unsophisticated to be like but then
you're being dishonest I think it's
actually selfish to unload it on
somebody else and give them the trauma
of imagining what we do know about
infidelity is that it can create an
actual post-traumatic stress like
experience for the Betrayed partner
where they are having intrusive thoughts
about it
um those are unwanted thoughts and it's
uncontrolled it comes in it multiple
times a day they'll have depressed mood
they'll have nightmares about it their
entire sense of security safety
self-esteem gets shattered because of
your actions
I think it's uh kind of yeah moralistic
and naive to think well they deserve to
know the truth if you actually know the
harm that that sort of betrayal does
um
especially if you truly mean to stop it
right so if it is if it was a one and
done or if it happened and you've
stopped it and you do not intend to do
it again frankly I think you live with
that burden
you live with that discomfort thank you
for saying that because I I totally
agree but it's it's like logically
it's doesn't quite make sense to give
that advice but psychologically makes
complete sense because you really are
destroying another person's mind uh
their faith in in love in relationships
their their their trust everything and
then you're imprisoning them to be stuck
with you for months or years if you're
trying to work through it through that
torture so you should be carrying that
burden and working through it I think
why why do you say that that's your
personal opinion versus your therapeutic
like what well I think everybody has
different values right so I think that's
a value-based decision because to me the
hierarchy is kindness and do no like do
no further harm yeah
um over
that's in that case over truth right
um whereas other people you know my
husband for instance he is like truth
above all else you don't get to decide
what I know or you know you don't get to
decide whether or not I can handle that
knowledge so he would even see my
determination of you know that I should
carry the burden sort of arrogant like
well why don't you let your partner
decide whether or not they you know why
do you get to choose I don't know I I
think there's value to both arguments I
absolutely see this point I absolutely
see his point and his I think is like a
very humble sort of option like
you don't get to choose what's better
you you just need to give them the
information and they can choose
but I think I don't know I think it's
kinder to hold I think it's going to
cause your conscience more discomfort to
hold it and I think there's sort of a
cleansing we do when we share that
information I think in real life most
people disclose it because they can't
stand the secret anymore themselves that
to me is a selfish act I have a
unemployment applications and so on and
just with friends would ask people what
do you care more about truth or loyalty
just to get to see how they think about
those different questions
and uh yeah the
I was surprised how much variance there
is on that and also conceptually I bet
I conceptually I don't think we actually
know where we stand until we're faced
with a situation like that yeah I think
people a lot of people especially when
they're younger say especially if
they're kind of intellectual they'll say
truth Above All Else
it's like all right you're exactly right
all right
until you get to hear a truth that truly
breaks you it truly hurts you or causes
suffering to you and then you realize or
a truth you give to somebody else will
cause them suffering right and they get
to see that suffering destroy their life
and maybe your relationship and so on
and then you're like oh yeah like should
I sit my dad down right now and be like
Dad your dementia like you have dementia
again today I'm going to tell you Dad
you're not making sense no we're go it's
not going to be discussed we're going to
make them comfortable and I mean yeah I
think it truth can be a little bit of a
platitude Sometimes some of those
complexities are all the things involved
in in the challenges of what makes a
relationship work right